من الشمال الى مدينه غزه وصولا للوسط وخان
يونس واخيرا رفح والان ماذا بعد رفح سؤال
يطرحه مئات الاف النازحين فالحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه دخلت شهرها
الخامس بحيله عسكريه فادحه في العرف
الاسرائيلي وحيله انسانيه ثقيله على
الفلسطينيين عاد الجيش الاسرائيلي ليقاتل
في الشمال
تشتعل مدينه غزه باشتباكات ضاريه توقع
خسائر في الوحدات المهاجمه فما عاد في
جعبه رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو خيارات ليجرب الا الذهاب الى رفح
ليعلن ديوان رئاسه الوزراء ان نتنياهو
اوعز باعداد خطه مزدوجه لاجلاء
الفلسطينيين وسحق كتائب حماس في رفح كما
يقول البيان مستدركا انه لا يمكن تحقيق
اهداف الحرب بالابقاء على اربع كتائب
مقاتله لحماس في رفح بحسب البيان الرسمي
رفح التي باتت ملجا لاكثر من نصف سكان
القطاع الذين هجرتهم اسرائيل على مدى اشهر
الحرب وصلوا اليها كمحطات نزوح خمسه ربما
وللكثير منهم هي اكثر من
الخامسه سبقت الحرب البريه حمله قصف مكثفه
جويا وبريا وبحريا ثم اطلقت اسرائيل ما
تسميها مناورات بريه دفع القصف العنيف
وفضائح قوات الاحتلال سكان المنطقه
الشماليه في بيت لاهيا وجباليا والجوار
الى النزوح بدايه لاحياء مدينه غزه ثم وسط
القطاع في النصيرات ودير البلح والبريج
نزوح تدريجي بعد استنفاد خيارات البقاء
شمالا ولو الى حين
انذاك زعمت قوات الاحتلال انها خصصت شارع
صلاح الدين ممرا امنا لكنها ظلت تستهدفه
وتقتل المدنيين العابرين الى الوسط ثم
وسعت من عملياتها وهاجمت مخيمات المنطقه
الوسطى دون ان تغير من شكل هجماتها بقي
المدنيون هدفا لها دفعتهم الى دير البلح
وقتلتهم هناك ايضا تلتها منطقه خانيونس
تصفها قوات الاحتلال بانها معقل كتائب
القسام وبان البنيه التحتيه العسكريه
للمقاومه تتركز فيها دفعت المدنيين الى
منطقه المواصي واستهدفت هناك قصفا
وقنصا وبدلت الويه ودفعت اثمان باهظه فيها
وتسرب في اليوم الثاني من الشهر الخامس
صحيفه النيويورك تايمز ان اسرائيل فشلت
بالدرجه الاولى في تفكيك قدره المقاومه
وفي اليوم عينه يريد نتنياهو فتح جبهه رفح
تحاول واشنطن ثنيه عن ذلك وتحذر الامم
المتحده من ان الاقتراب عسكريا من رفح
يعني تهديد قرابه مليون و300 الف نازح على
الاقل في مساحه لا تتجاوز
66 كيلومترا
مربعا بينما تتجدد المعارك في مناطق جزم
الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه احكم سيطرته
عليها